hey guys it's wednesday october twenty
eighth I'm Mary Kish and you're watching
gamespot news we've had a lot of news
for Fallout recently but if you're
looking for any news regarding the mods
of Fallout you're gonna have to wait
until after the game's release with less
than two weeks to go before fallout 4 is
released Bethesda is focusing on
launching the game and is told fans not
to expect news about post-release items
such as mods right now responding to
questions on Twitter about Fallout 4 pc
mods Bethesda's marketing executive Pete
Hines said if it's okay with you we're
going to focus on the game release first
and talk about mods when we figured some
stuff out fallout 4s mod tools the
Creation Kit won't be available at
launch on November 10 instead coming
sometime early 2015 players can create
mods on PC and then share them in
addition some mods created on PC will be
playable first on Xbox one before coming
to playstation 4 later fallout 4
launches on November 10th for xbox one
ps4 and PC are you playing rocket League
because if you're not you should play
rocket League you guys want to talk
about rocket League a free update is
coming to rocket league that promises to
introduce a number of new ways to play
psionics will add mutators to the game
which change at the formula in a number
of interesting sounding ways one of the
mutaters is a low grab the variant
called moon ball while others cubic and
time warp take inspiration from rocket
league predecessor supersonic acrobatic
rocket-powered battle cars the November
update also introduces a new playlist
called mutator mashup that combines some
of these in a randomized list psionics
also teased a highly requested mutator
mode inspired by the real world sport of
hockey which will release in December
more details about the upcoming mutator
update for rocket League will be
announced tomorrow October 29 through a
twitch livestream starting at two p.m.
this year Kojima has had his ups and his
downs but thanks to his good friend and
cult horror movie maker John Carpenter
he got to avoid some serious legal
trouble director John Carpenter the man
behind the hits Halloween
thing and escape from new york has
revealed how he stopped Metal Gear Solid
creator Hideo Kojima from being sued in
an interview with The Hollywood Reporter
carpenter explains that canal plus the
French company who share the rights to
escape from new york were keen to sue
Konami over the perceived copyright
infringement of the classic 1982 sci-fi
movie they wanted to go after the video
game metal gear solid which is kind of a
rip off of Escape from New York but I
told them not to do that I know the
director of those games he's a nice guy
at least he's nice to me Metal Gear
Solid similarities from escape to New
York end with its main character who
does bear a striking resemblance the
film's hero Snake Plissken played by
Kurt Russell even down to the fact that
he's called Solid Snake however last
year Kojima tweeted that this wasn't a
reason at all stating the reason I used
snake as code name in Metal Gear was
snake was the most appropriate symbol of
a living thing that hides his presence
if you're planning on going as a snake
this Halloween there's still time to
back out before you're sued by Canal+ so
I think I speak on behalf of everyone
when I say thank you John Carpenter not
just for helping out Kojima but for one
of the best or movies ever thing you
should watch that this Halloween and for
news you can catch me the same place
same time tomorrow see you then
you